so this one I want to go back to when I
was a student I was in high school and a
friend of mine who knew I was kind of a
math person came up and he's like hey
Grant
do you get like money if you can find
really big prime numbers like I don't
know maybe he's like because I think I
found a way that you can get uh uh any
any arbitrarily big prime number that
you want his name was Patrick Patterson
this is the Patrick Patterson patented
method for generating bigger primes uh
do you want to give me your favorite
prime number it could be a small one
I would go 17. all right so we'll take
17. and the method is we're going to
write this in base four so in base four
you have the one spot you've got the
four spot and you've got the 16 spot and
it could go on with other powers of 4
64. but in this case 16 is big enough
because we would write this as 1 16 and
then you don't need to add any fours and
then there's a single one in there this
is what that number looks like in base
four and his observation was hey if you
read this as if it's base 10 and you
ignore the fact that it's writing the
number in base four 101 is also a prime
in base 10. and you say well that's just
one prime let's try it with a different
one do you have another favorite prime
number three so three is pretty simple
um three is just also three in base four
the next one you know a little bit less
obvious five and eleven is also Prime in
base 10. awesome and this keeps going
actually so if you try it with seven you
get 13. if we try this with 11 that's
also Prime and this was the pattern and
he notices that no matter what prime
number he seemed to plug in you always
seem to get out another prime number and
you know it follows for these first few
seems like a natural enough rule
therefore it goes on forever
you have to know prime numbers to make
prime well but you can see how the skin
goes you just start with one and I have
to for example maybe we do this 101 the
one we spat out there yeah actually
let's try that let's try that let's try
that yeah there's going to be a single
64 so then how many do we need in the
16s place two of them in there to get 32
and then this leaves us with one four
and one one now I don't know off the top
of my head if
1211 is prime uh tragically sorry to say
for Patrick uh this one is not actually
Prime this is seven times 173. and so
you know this is this is before it was
very common for you know kids in school
to be programming things certainly so
you probably didn't check that far but
what is true what I can tell you is not
a coincidence that we see a seven in
here and if you just go through with
your normal pattern and you try this
with all of the primes you can so all of
the primes up to that point the rule
works pretty well so you know very sad
the pattern breaks this is not going to
be the scheme to just plug in new ones
and constantly get bigger ones but it's
kind of interesting to ask why why did
it seem to work for so long and in this
case it's not actually that hard to see
why it's decently reasonable that this
would be happening for the small numbers
and then break down for larger ones
first of all if it's even in base 10
it's also even in base four and this is
because 4 is also an even number so any
number in base 4 that's even it's going
to end with a zero or it's going to end
with a 2. and what that means is if it's
not even in base 10 there's definitely
not even in base four if two did not go
into your original number two also does
not divide the bigger one slightly less
obvious is that the same thing happens
for three where a lot of people might
know a divisibility trick for three you
have some large number like nine
thousand seven hundred and thirty two
someone goes and they asks you hey is
this number divisible by three the trick
is to say if you add up all of those
digits nine plus seven plus three plus
two and you ask if that's numbers
divisible by three that's 21 21 is
divisible by three so we'd say yes this
one actually three does divide that
number and the reason this works is
basically because the number 10 the base
that we're using is one above a multiple
of three and the idea there is that if
we expand out what this whole number
actually means we're saying we take nine
times ten to the power 3 plus 7 times 10
squared all very Elementary
sort of literally Elementary it's what
we learned in elementary school but
let's say we want to say reduce this mod
3. which is a way of saying what is the
remainder that this number will leave
when we divide it by the number three
the way that you can think about this is
that when you reduce things mod three or
you ask about this kind of remainder
operation a very nice fact is that
operations like multiplication and
addition play nicely with reduction and
what I mean by that is if I take
something like a plus b and then ask for
what is that when we reduce mod 3 what
is the remainder when you divide by
three that's going to be the same as if
I take a mod 3 and I add it to whatever
B mod 3 is
I can kind of reduce them before I do
the actual addition operation if you
take two very large numbers like I've
got 90 plus 73 and I want to know uh
what's the remainder when I divide by
three I can just take the remainder
beforehand on each one of them 90 it's
going to be 0 73 it's going to be one so
I don't actually have to add the numbers
in order to know the reduction of their
sum same deal with products you know if
I multiply the two numbers doesn't
matter if I do it before or after when
you're thinking of the expansion of a
big number like this 10 because 10 is
just one mod 3 we can think of the
expansion by saying this is the same as
saying 9 times 1 to the power 3 plus 7
times 1 to the power 2.
and three times one to the power 1 and
2. the reason we can just add the digits
is because the thing each one gets
multiplied in the expansion as far as
you know the universe mod 3 is concerned
all of those are the same thing as one
and of course the point here is the same
would work with four if you're doing it
in base four and what that means is if
you're given a number that's not
divisible by 3 in base 10 and then you
write it in base four this rule with the
digits and whether the digits add up to
a multiple of three or not that's also
going to hold and slightly more subtle
is also if it's not divisible by five uh
once you reduce the base four
the um if the original number wasn't
divisible by five the new one you see
interpreted in base 10 won't be but that
it's a little bit more subtle in this
case it's a it's a nice Coincidence of
two facts one the 10 is divisible by
five so you know if a number is going to
be divisible by five only if you end in
a zero or a five it's one of the first
things we know about divisibility if we
learn about it as Elementary schoolers
but then in base four there is no five
so the last digit could never be a five
and if the last digit is a zero it must
have been even so assuming it wasn't
even there's nothing that you can write
in base four that would be divisible by
five and so the first prime number
that's even available to divide one of
these Expressions that we get by
starting with a prime and writing in
phase four would be seven
so in some sense all of these numbers
are immune to divisibility by two three
and five which actually rules out quite
a bit but they don't have that same
immunity from 7 or 13 or 11 and all of
the next ones so using the Paterson
technique yeah exactly you are never
going to spit out a number in base 10
that has two three or five as one of its
prime factors exactly ever in history
exactly yeah and it's for for small
numbers that accounts for most of the
possibilities for what could be dividing
it in fact up until you get to 49 that's
enough to guarantee that you're Prime
because 49 is the first composite number
where its divisors are all strictly
above five and after that it's just sort
of a random toss-up whether or not you
hit divisors or not so 59 you happen to
hit it 101 very sadly you happen to get
it maybe we could have gotten a string
that was a little bit longer you know we
can kind of see it here like you start
with five you get out 11 and if you
start 11 you get out 23 if you start
with 23 113 like looks pretty Prime as
far as I'm concerned so if you're you
know if you're a school kid and you're
Pleasant messing around you might think
this is plenty true enough what should
someone watching this video take from
this that's the right kind of question
to ask
um I mean this is this is all Loosely
related to something Richard guy
described as the strong law of small
numbers I'm going to paraphrase but
small numbers can't support the weight
that we give them with all the patterns
that they have to hold and you're just
going to run into these kinds of
coincidences
um I can show you another one if you
want that is in a similar vein you know
I'm going to say yes all right I'll get
you another piece of paper okay we'll
get another one
[Music]
so yes this is to be continued and see
the links in the video description for
details of the next video in this
interview
also check out Grant's channel three
blue one brown for a whole other video
he's just released about false patterns
in the meantime on screen as you can
probably see are the first 1000 prime
numbers in base 10 converted to base 4
and then checked for Paterson primality
no twos threes or fives in those prime
factors just like Grant promised
[Music]
as you can see things start strongly but
then start tailing off in fact only 388
of the first 1000 prime numbers past
Patrick's test
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
terrorism I think
um
check out all the usual links for more
videos and information and of course
make sure you're up to date with Grant's
Channel that's three blue one brown
always amazing stuff to be seen there
there's really only two rations
[Music]